foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear
so I talked a little bit about the kind
of like Powerhouse horror novelist Dean
Koontz a while back can't remember
exactly what it was
um I think it was back when I reviewed
what's probably like the best screen
adaptation of his work at least to date
which is uh the massively underrated uh
2013 movie Odd Thomas which started the
late Anton Yelchin uh which is a great
movie by the way I did a review of IT a
while back um you know and it's really
good so check it out I don't know one of
the weirdest things about Dean koontz's
body of work I guess is that he's
written a [ __ ] ton of novels that sell
in the millions I mean at least from my
understanding uh I think that he's like
the second best-selling horror novelist
of all time after Stephen King obviously
but
in spite of that like comparatively few
of his books have been adapted to movies
and then when they do get adapted they
tend to be like pretty lackluster you
don't really hear much about them or
they get like really poorly received and
sort of like forgotten about I'm really
not sure why nobody's been able to do
like a big like definitive adaptation of
a Dean Koontz novel
it seems like a a strange amount of them
too are uh adapted into TV movies which
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
bad because I've seen some really good
TV movies but it does seem very bizarre
to me like how an author with such a
presumably massive following you would
think uh can't really seem to Merit a
really good quality like Cinema
adaptation of one of his books it seems
like it hasn't really happened yet so as
a case in point I actually wanted to
talk about the Servants of Twilight
which is a 1991 made for TV adaptation
of Dean kuntz's 1984 novel which is
actually written under a pseudonym
initially uh Lee Nichols and was
originally just called Twilight although
as far as I could determine the title
was changed like a long time before the
much more famous like Stephanie Meyer
books came onto the scene
so Servants of Twilight was another one
of those movies uh you know again like
the mostly forgotten 1989 movie
Cameron's closet like that I talked
about a little while like you know a
couple weeks ago or whatever that I seem
to have seen like a few times back on
cable back in the 1990s and even though
I barely remembered anything about
whether it was particularly good or bad
or like whether I liked it or not like
it's just seemed like something about it
must have stuck with me to such an
extent that when I was like scrolling
through to be I was curious and have to
be like oh yeah I remember something
about that movie like some part of it
that like stuck with me so I decided
that I was gonna re-watch it so Servants
of Twilight was actually directed by
Jeffrey o'brow ah brow I'm not really
sure you pronounced his last name now he
actually got his start in horror with
the low budget like 1982 slasher the
dorm that dripped blood and then he went
on and directed the power in 1984 which
I think I've seen a couple of times and
the Kindred in 1987 which I think I
actually saw in the theater believe it
or not and saw couple of times on a
cable subsequently
now Servants of Twilight was I think
like his first television film and it
was also his last collaboration with
like his long time writing directing
partner whose name is Stephen Carpenter
and Stephen Carpenter would actually go
on to create the very long-running Grimm
television series like the ones like
about fairy tale type of thing I think
that ran from like 2011 to 2017 so that
was the guy behind that there were
actually like quite a few things to like
about Servants of Twilight uh it's been
high point at least in my opinion is the
cast which actually includes the
Australian actress Belinda Bauer who was
in Flashdance RoboCop 2 like among other
things uh the very prolific character
actor Bruce Greenwood who I think he
played uh Pike in the you know the
Abrams Star Trek movies he was in
Gerald's Game he was in Dr sleep so he's
done some movies with Mike Flanagan like
he's been in a million movies uh Jack
Kehoe I think is how you pronounce his
last name he was in Serpico and the
sting like a lot of those kind of like
movies from the 70s and you got two day
David Lynch regulars as well the always
creepy and awesome Grace zabriskie is in
this and the big tall guy like uh you
know the the guy that plays like the
Giant on Twin Peaks uh Carol striking
striking as I think how you pronounce
his last name he's Dutch uh so the movie
also I have to say like features one of
the better child performances like from
this era and from this type of film uh
the kid actor was named Jarrett Lennon
he actually comes across as like really
natural and very very sympathetic
Jarrett Lennon incidentally uh worked
pretty steadily I guess like as a child
actor into like his teen years or so you
know around there and then probably
pretty sensibly like took a long break
um you know got a degree went and worked
in I.T uh you know it had like a normal
life raised a family and whatnot and
then fairly recently like 2015 he got
back into acting again and started
touring with like an indie improv group
which have had some success so I thought
that was like pretty cool now although I
haven't read the novel that the Servants
of Twilight is based on I did actually
read a very detailed synopsis of it and
from my understanding uh the movie I
guess like toned down maybe some of the
more like bigger like epic aspects of
the extended Chase sequence that sort of
like comprises the bulk in the narrative
I guess and they probably did that for
budgetary reasons I imagine like some of
the stuff is in there but like some of
the bigger set pieces obviously they
would have had to kind of scale that
back a little bit also seems like it
spends less time with the supposed
villains of the piece uh they seem to
have been given more dimension in the
novel and it seemed like there were some
scenes that were particularly like from
the main big bad like from her point of
view whereas you don't really get that
in the movie like she is in the movie
but you don't really see things from her
POV like for any uh you know significant
amount of time
now the book also apparently leaves the
ending ambiguous whereas the film's
ending is very explicitly defined and
that's a decision I wasn't really on
board with
now because I would actually like to
touch on the reasons I thought the movie
should have stuck with the novel's more
uncertain resolution uh this discussion
going forward is going to have spoilers
for both the book and the movie so
consider this your warning you know like
I said this was 80s and 90s so if you
don't want it spoiled then maybe like go
read it or watch it or whatever and then
come back because I'm gonna like pretty
much say what happened at the end
because I can't discuss my
dissatisfaction with the way that it was
adapted if I can't talk about that so at
the beginning of the movie We're
introduced to a single mom uh named
Christine and her son Joey who's about
nine years old I think that's about how
old the actor was anyway after a very
brief period of just kind of like
establishing their you know very normal
loving relationship you know how normal
their interactions are picking the kid
up from school getting them ice cream
[ __ ] like that we're kind of like pretty
soon into the story we're thrown a
curveball in the form of spooky ass
Grace zabriskie now she approaches the
two of them the mother and son in in
like a mall parking garage now at first
like for the first couple of minutes she
seems like a little bit weird and
invasive but she isn't being too crazy
initially
um you know she's like oh what a
handsome little boy and that kind of
stuff like talking like one of those
kind of like meddlesome old bitties who
don't understand personal space and
always want to like you know grab your
baby's cheeks and [ __ ] like that uh but
then you know very very soon into it
like she ramps up the insanity pretty
much like starts screeching at Joey that
she knows what he is and telling
Christine that the boy will have to die
so you know that's a little upsetting
now Christine understandably uh shoves
the deranged woman out the way uh jumps
in the car and peels the [ __ ] out of the
parking garage now Joey again
understandably is pretty shaken by this
whole experience and he's actually
convinced that the woman is a witch and
later that night he tells his mom that
that same lady was kind of like skulking
around outside his bedroom window
now Christine doesn't believe this at
first but then the next morning they
actually find their golden retriever
Brandy beheaded on the porch uh which
thankfully they don't show they just
like explain it you know what I mean so
I'm just like well you know if you're
gonna kill the dogs at least don't show
it so thank you very much for that so
Christine calls the cops as you would if
somebody beheaded your [ __ ] dog so
the police officer who shows up is
maddeningly dismissive
surprisingly uh apparently he doesn't
believe that they actually saw this
woman and he really doesn't seem to give
two shits about a dog being beheaded
which like I said seems like a little
threatening to me uh not you know just
aside from the fact that you're killing
a beautiful animal you know what I mean
uh basically he tells them before he
leaves why don't you just like trust in
God and stop bothering the authorities
with their [ __ ] essentially now
there is a reason I think like for the
officer acting like this but you don't
actually find out what it is until later
on and actually it didn't even really
occur to me because it was just like
such a nothing scene that I forgot about
it until like later on then I was like
oh I guess that's why that cop was
acting like that you know what I mean
they don't state it outright but like as
The Story Goes On you figure out why he
was acting that way so because Christine
and Joey are now very clearly being
followed by this mysterious white van
that pretty much magically shows up like
wherever they are Christine you know
knowing that she can't go to the cops
because they don't give a crap um she's
desperate so she turns to this private
investigator named Charlie
now I'm not sure if I missed it I'm not
really sure how Christine had heard of
him
and why she went to him specifically
because there is a scene where she goes
to the office and there's another
investigator there and she's like yeah
and the secretary's like yeah that you
know she doesn't want to talk to you she
was waiting for Charlie so I guess she
heard about in summer or something like
maybe he had some kind of like
reputation that preceded him and that
was maybe delineated more in the novel I
just didn't know like how she knew about
him but you know maybe that was cut for
time who who knows now regardless uh
Charlie who actually retired he's still
an investigator but he retired from
field work like a year before like after
the death of his wife because he had a
hard time dealing with it
um he agrees to take Christine's case on
largely because he seems to feel like
really drawn to her like in a way he
can't really explain and he just
suddenly feels this Burning need to
protect her and her son from this insane
woman who seems to have targeted them
for reasons unknown now somewhere around
here as Charlie agrees to take their
case and kind of like befriends them a
little bit Charlie ends up getting Joey
another dog and it looks exactly like
the first dog only this time Joey calls
him Chewbacca instead of Brandy was like
the first one uh this second dog uh you
know will be an important plot Point
later on so that's kind of why they
spend a little bit of time on it so as
the story continues Charlie discovers
that the insane stalker woman is named
Grace Spivey and she's supposedly some
kind of weird preacher and she's the
head of this kind of loony apocalyptic
cult called the Servants of Twilight
obviously who essentially like believe
that it's the end times you know what I
mean now her and her minions are
convinced that Joey is the Antichrist
and they will stop at absolutely nothing
to essentially like wipe him off the
face of the Earth
now once this fact is established the
movie becomes pretty much just like one
long Chase sequence as Charlie Christine
and Joey are forced to stay on the move
to evade the cultists now the cultists
somehow always seem to be like one or
two steps ahead of them like one time
for example uh some of the followers
even show up at this random hotel that
they stop at and it's implied that the
cultists got there before the trio did
you know what I mean like how did they
know that so Charlie can't really figure
out how the Twilight Nutters like always
know where they're gonna be like
especially since they're very very
careful about not telling anybody their
plans now early on when Charlie actually
meets with Grace briefly to see if he
can reason with her a spoiler alert he
can't
um it's implied that she might be
psychic and that all the other followers
are able to essentially quote unquote
feel the boys evil so they're like well
the child child will never be able to
hide from us because we can always like
sense where he's at later on though
there's actually given like a more
pragmatic explanation
um because it comes to light that like a
mentor and Associate of Charlie's who
was supposedly helping them like in
their escape was actually on the side of
the cult and was like reporting their
whereabouts to the wackos so finally
after Charlie Christine and Joey have
you know repeatedly failed to elude
Grace and her followers the three of
them decide you know they can't run
anymore and they're just gonna make this
final stand at this remote cabin that
they've been staying at that belongs to
a friend of Charlie's now during this
last confrontation
Charlie gets like wounded like taken out
of commission and Christine is
apparently killed now Grace's right-hand
man Kyle who's played by Carol stricken
like I said the you know the big tall
guy from the David Lynch movies he was
supposed to be the one to kill the kid
like he was supposed to be God's Hammer
you know what I mean but he was having
like crises of Faith like all through
this whole thing like he didn't think he
could do it he's like oh he's just a kid
and you know what if we're wrong and all
this other kind of [ __ ] and then you
know Grace is always like well this is
God testing your faith and the kid is
Satan and blah blah and all this other
kid you have to do it and you know so
when it comes down to it you know Kyle's
supposed to kill the kid but he can't do
it because you know he has empathy he's
like he's just a boy it's just a boy
he's like I can't do it
um and Joey looks really cute and he's
like please don't kill me please don't
kill me you know what I mean so it's
like that so Grace is basically like
well [ __ ] I just you know you keep you
have to do anything you have to do
everything yourself uh so so she goes to
like blow the kids head off but before
she can
like a swarm of bats kind of comes
swooping into the cabin and kill her
and subsequently Joey appears to bring
his mother back to life
a fact which causes Charlie to wonder if
the cultists weren't actually right
about the kid all along now I forgot to
mention this before uh but the movie is
actually told as a sort of extended
flashback like Charlie is telling this
whole crazy episode to a psychiatrist
friend of his whose name is Dr booth now
three months have passed since the
incident and in that time Charlie has
actually become convinced that Joey
actually is the Antichrist and has to be
destroyed now Dr Booth obviously thinks
he's lost the plot but Charlie starts
laying out all the evidence uh including
like the bat swarm that killed Grace the
supposed resurrection of Christine he's
like you know I saw she was dead blah
blah blah and the fact that Joey's
father was just some random dude that
Christine met on a cruise whose name she
didn't even know
he then tells Dr Booth that he's even
certain that the second dog that they
got for the kid Chewbacca was actually
the exact same dog Brandy that was
beheaded early in the film and that the
kid had apparently brought the dog back
to life so as proof Charlie says I went
to the pet cemetery and dug up Brandy's
body and I found a completely different
dead dog in the grave now as far as I'm
aware at least according to the synopsis
that I read this is how the book left
things with Charlie basically like
starting to consider the possibility
that maybe Joey was actually who the
cult said he was maybe not he's not
really sure and I actually really liked
this ambiguity and it was also kind of
framed like that in the first like two
acts of the movie pretty much everything
that happened and you could tell they
were deliberately setting it up like
this pretty much everything that
happened could either be attributed one
to Joey being the Antichrist like the
cult said or just to like weird
coincidences you know what I mean like
for example Grace could have really been
psychic with a line to where the kid was
going to be at any given time but then
the story explicitly lays out the fact
that Charlie's kind of supposed friend
was working for the enemy he was like a
mole and he told the cult members where
they were which would explain how they
would always find them additionally like
the fact that the wrong dog was in the
grave was explained away like by a
cemetery caretaker who you know Charlie
was like it's the wrong dog this isn't
the dog is supposed to be in there and
the caretaker like laughs at me was like
look nobody cares like which dog ends up
in which hole it's like Mix-Ups happen
all the time it's a pet cemetery nobody
really gives much of a crap so you know
that could have been explained away like
that and I mean the bats that killed
Grace could have been just like a weird
fluke or like Mass rabies or some [ __ ]
like that and Christine coming back from
the dead supposedly might also not have
been miraculous I mean the paramedics
had just stopped working on her she'd
only been flatlined for a minute or two
and then Joey kind of like hugged her
and said oh please come back and blah
blah and that kind of just caused her to
wake up which that's happened in real
life before it says you know what I mean
it's not like she'd been dead for like a
year and then suddenly he like touched
her and she came out I mean she just
like died supposedly so I mean
everything in other words could have had
a completely rational explanation and I
liked that they laid it out like that
and honestly I feel like that's where
the movie should have ended because I
found it like a really intriguing idea
to have this lingering doubt like in the
Charlie character he had spent all this
time protecting this mother and child
even falling in love with Christine
along the way like even considering
marrying her but then a couple
inexplicable things occurred which made
him questioned everything that he had
invested so much like time and emotion
into like had the end of the movie been
left open as it presumably was in the
book it would have really been an
interesting examination into how a
normal person like Charlie could come to
believe in outrageous things you know I
mean like how easy it would be to sway
someone into batshittery like once
certain suggestions have been planted in
their mind you know what I mean now I
will note at at least from my reading of
the novel synopsis it was perhaps
implied that Joey very well might have
been the Antichrist but I don't think it
was ever stated outright
um which was the whole reason for having
every incident kind of feature this
aspect of plausible deniability to it
because you never knew but see no the
movie didn't do that the movie had to go
and very boldly established that yes
Joey's the Antichrist and he's evil and
the Servants of Twilight who killed
multiple innocent people and at least
two dogs over the course of the movie
were correct in their beliefs
so at the end of the movie there's kind
of like this Coda where Joey and
Chewbacca the dog come to visit Charlie
in the sanitarium or wherever it is that
he's staying at and Joey essentially
tells like Charlie's like um I know like
I know that you're the Antichrist and
the kid's like yeah I know you know what
I mean so he's like that and then like
later on he's talking to him and he
tells Charlie that you know despite his
powers that's not what he says but
that's like the implication he's like
well I still needed a dad but now you
can't be my dad because you know he's
not down with the evil right so the kid
basically does the Darth Vader Force
choke on him and kills the guy like
right there in the couch in the rec room
so he just like kills Charlie at the end
so I had some problems with his ending
as you might imagine now the whole you
know crazy murderous religious people
turn out to be right all along Trope
that has been done before but offhand I
can really only think of one movie where
it was done right and that would be the
excellent 2001 film Frailty which was
you know directed by the late great Bill
Paxton which you haven't seen it that's
a fantastic film most other times that
this trick is pulled in a movie it kind
of like pisses me right off I mean I
guess because the filmmakers what
they're essentially doing they're
retroactively justifying the horrific
actions of the villains in the service
of a cheap twist although to be honest
maybe the filmmakers or the writers or
whoever comes up the story isn't really
thinking about the implications all that
much they're just like oh this will be
like a Twist you know what I mean but I
don't know like to me I just I don't
know I don't like that twist usually
like I said Frailty was awesome it got
away with it but most of the other ones
like that don't and the thing about the
film version of the service of Twilight
is that even though the reveal of Joey
as yeah he was the Antichrist all along
is played as a Twist you could still see
it coming a mile away even though right
up until the end I kept hoping I was
like I know that they're gonna make him
really be the Antichrist but I was I was
really hoping that they wouldn't go
there they wouldn't do that I mean
honestly honestly I would have even
preferred it if the twist had been that
Joey was Supernatural but was actually
the second coming of Jesus and the
cultist got it completely wrong like it
was like opposite like that would have
been awesome like if they wanted to go
that route because that would have been
because for a second I thought that's
what they were gonna do like when she
when he resurrected the mom I was like
oh it's gonna be like you know the the
cult were still the bad guys because
they thought oh he's the Antichrist but
actually he's Jesus so I was like that
would have been a lot cooler so I was
kind of hoping that they did that but no
they didn't and I mean barring that like
I don't know did you really have to have
a Twist at all I I really think he
didn't I mean I think I would have
preferred that all the events hinting
that Joey was evil were left unclear so
you could read the film as Charlie
having fallen for the cult's [ __ ]
too or if you wanted to believe that
Joey was the Antichrist all along and
that the cultists were right then you
could also read it that way I think it
was like better to like leave it
ambiguous you know I don't know I mean I
suppose I just don't have like much
patience with a movie that posits that
murderous religious Fanatics are correct
and like justified in their actions
especially when the book didn't even go
there and I think it would have been
like a richer story if they hadn't just
definitively come down on one side or
the other I mean all that said uh the
Servants of Twilight the movie it's
still like a serviceable movie it's
still worth watching if you're really
into Dean Koontz uh the acting is
actually quite good and there are some
like really good suspensable sequences I
will admit though that I kind of wish
that the mystery of who Grace was and
all the specifics of the cult agenda
were drawn out for a little bit longer I
mean once it was established and it was
pretty early on in the story that Grace
and the servants wanted Joey dead
because they believed he was the
Antichrist there wasn't really anywhere
else for the narrative to go like you
know the mystery had been solved and the
rest of it was just you know after that
it just kind of became a series of set
pieces where the protagonists would move
to a new location the cult would
immediately find them there'd be kind of
like a fight and then rinse and repeat
you know what I mean like for the rest
of the movie and as I mentioned like the
end I just found that the end like a tad
infuriating as the way the story built
up I was either hoping that Joey's
nature would be left inconclusive which
would have been like I said made it like
a more deep story or more like thing
like more thought-provoking I guess or
that there would be a Switcheroo if you
had to have a Twist like there could be
a Switcheroo and Joey would turn out to
be like a messiah or something like that
like and not the Antichrist like he'd be
like a good guy but vindicating the cult
I mean that just kind of left a bad
taste in my mouth and even from a
storytelling standpoint it just seemed
like a really lazy like obvious gotcha
you know so I guess I didn't love it
from that perspective either so I still
stand by my assertion that Odd Thomas
from 2013 is so far the best Coons
adaptation that I've seen I haven't seen
them all so you know uh but this one
isn't terrible by any means uh it wasn't
boring and I didn't have any trouble
getting invested in the story like I
said you know the the acting is good so
the characters you know you get invested
and you actually kind of care about them
um the ending while annoying uh didn't
ruin it for me but I can totally see why
this movie got mostly negative reviews
when it you know showed on TV or
whatever and has kind of fallen into
relative obscurity since then so have
you seen the Servants of Twilight what
did you think about it uh did you like
it did you hate it what is your favorite
Dean Koontz adaptation please tell me
down in the comments and that will do it
for this flickers of fear I'll see you
guys again on the next one bye